James Spader could possibly return to
the Stargate franchise but should he and
how would it even work welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
so first of all I've got to say that
this is firmly in the rumor category
it's a rumor I've heard from a couple of
different sources now and if hand on my
heart I suspect it comes from the fact
that James Spader is finishing in his
series The Blacklist at the moment and
with Stargate coming back there has been
discussions MGM about whether they
should approach James Spader to return
for Stargate now I can completely
understand why Executives at MGM would
think this is a good idea basically it
would be a big name and it would really
excite fans he could appear in a quite a
small part just a cameo maybe or as a
semi-recurring character we just don't
know but if he did return
would he still be Daniel Jackson first
of all I have to say that my sources are
telling me that actually if he did
return he would not be back as Daniel
Jackson now I actually think there's a
possibility he could return as an
alternative Daniel Jackson we've already
seen alternative universities after all
and then you could kind of tie the movie
in with the series by saying actually
the movie was that universe and the TV
series is the prime universe or whatever
and that actually we can have two Daniel
Jackson's in the new franchise
as I say though my sources are telling
me that he probably will not be Daniel
Jackson but he will be a completely
different character now we have seen
this in reboots before where an actor
from the original come back in a
different role so it's not completely
beyond the Realms of possibility but
let's think first of all should he
well James Spader is an actor that I
absolutely adore I remember seeing him
in 1987's mannequin he played this
Weasley little character that all the
way through you're supposed to hate but
I just thought he was great and I
actually ended up remembering as a kid
watching this thinking I want that guy
to win I wanted him to get his day but
you know obviously he didn't now he
appeared in that movie with Kim Cattrall
Kim Cattrall is a lady that I might have
had a bit of a crush on when I was
little and to be honest might still do a
bit now
so I love the film mannequin I love
James Spader in it and I just thought
that is an actor I really like and I've
watched pretty much everything he's
appeared in ever since now don't get me
wrong he has done some awful movies some
really really bad films but every single
time he brings his a game he always just
fills up the screen he does steal almost
every scene he's in and James Spader
particularly when he's playing a bit of
a bad guy ugh he's glorious in Marvel
Age of Ultron he was the best bit of the
film to be honest again he stole every
scene he was in really he kind of stole
the movie he may actually be the best
Marvel villain we've seen so far the guy
in the most recent Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 and he pushes him he's pretty
damn good but Ultron
good villain
I also watched James Spade in something
called Boston Legal a TV show based in
his hometown of Boston now I watched
that show probably every two to three
years it's one of my favorite non-sci-fi
shows ever made with the brilliant
William Shatner who is just again
marvelous in this stuff those two the
flamingos if you've watched the series
you'll know I'm talking about together
we're just great bouncing off each other
it's as close to perfect television as I
think you can ever get now in 1994 when
Stargate came out I saw that This
brilliant actor who I had just adored in
mannequin was appearing in a movie with
Kurt Russell Jack Burton himself from
Big Trouble in Little China that I had
just adored since 1966 when that came
out
also at Camp Katrina
I think I might have a little bit of a
problem with Kim Cattrall
I think I love her so I saw these two
great actors in a film that I just
thought looked awesome and I was
straight to the cinema to watch it and
it was then that I became a gator then
Michael Shanks did a James Spader
impression in the early sg1 seasons and
I actually thought he did a great job of
it but I always thought it was better
when Michael Shanks stopped doing it and
made the character his own because to be
honest however good the impression of
James Spader was it was just an
impression he could never quite be as
brilliant as the original also I should
say that it is almost certain that
Michael Shanks will return to whatever
franchise my source has been telling me
for quite a long time now that Michael
Schantz is already verbally agreed to
return along with Amanda Tapping we will
be seeing the TV version of Daniel
Jackson not to worry
because obviously there is the threat of
James Spader returning does that mean
we're getting a hard reboot again
everything I've told you so far we're
not don't have to worry about it this is
going to be a continuation everything
I'm being told says it's going to be a
continuation Don't Panic so what
character would James Spader take on if
he's not being you know Daniel Jackson
well to be honest I'd love to see him in
sort of a villain role
from the very first movie to be honest
he could be the main villain moving then
into the franchise the TV series I would
absolutely love to see that maybe he's a
gold coming back you know some ancient
gold returning somebody that has you
know a bit more power than the original
gold maybe sort of on Anubis level
something that could actually try to
maybe get revenge against the Towery for
what they did to the gold or maybe it
comes back as like a politician or
something a role you know again a
Weasley character that I think he would
be brilliant at to be honest anything
that he does would be awesome I'd also
wouldn't mind seeing maybe is the new
leader of the SGC for example you know
maybe working alongside Daniel Jackson
that could give us some really brilliant
comedic moments
but if I'm really honest and handle my
heart
I hope he comes back as a villain
because that's when James Spade is at
its best Readington from The Blacklist
series was at his best when he was
actually being a bad guy
um Ultron obviously the ultimate bad guy
even really in Boston Legal where okay
he wasn't a bad guy necessarily but he
wasn't exactly a good person either a
lot of the time and we kind of loved him
at its best when he was kind of being
his worst he was a little bit of a
naughty boy let's say that but guys I'd
love for you to get into the comments
and tell me what you think should James
Spader return to the Stargate franchise
should he return as an alternative
version of Daniel Jackson or a different
character altogether I'd love to know
exactly what you think please get in the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you get to see them
without the adverts as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]